en perspective au nom france les
intermittents du spectacle qui
poursuivent leur mouvement commence à
connaître quelques difficultés pour
demeurer sur le devant de la scène
hier de manière emblématique qu'il
voulait s'en prendre aux concerts de
johnny hallyday en corrèze dédié au
couple chirac
ils ont échoué ils ont esté en coulisses
loin derrière alexandre kara arnaud
juste pour un peu jacques chirac aurait
volé la vedette à johnny en corrèze le
président est peut-être le seul à
pouvoir rivaliser avec le rockeur le
plus populaire de france
alors impossible de manquer se conserve
sur mesure organisée à la demande de
bernadette au profit d'une oeuvre de
charité
gigean
il y en a d'autres qui n'avaient fait le
déplacement pour jacques chirac est pas
pour devenir une poignée d'intermittents
du spectacle bien décidés à se faire
entendre
malgré un face à face un peu inégal avec
le milieu policier présent
nous allons investir les lieux
symboliquement on part on ne sait pas si
on peut rentrer et on ira distribué des
tracts à l'entrée on ne perturbera pas
le spectacle et si on ne peut pas
rentrer ben je sais pas ce qui va se
passer quoi réponse pas grand chose
la tentative fait long feu
résultat une évacuation un peu musclé
jamais les intermittents de ronds
approcher à moins de 800 mètres du lieu
du concert
pendant ce temps le spectacle se
poursuit normalement pour le plus grand
plaisir des 25000 spectateurs présents
mais un peu on est comme lui on prend de
l'âge
jacques et bernadette chirac sont restés
jusqu'à la fin du spectacle et les seuls
intermittents qu'ils ont conduit hier
soir sont ceux qui étaient sur sa part
fléchi maintenant un peu avec ce
week-end dernier à biarritz l'avant
dernière étape du championnat